they came out in their tens of thousands
connecting a hundred and seventy
kilometers of Lebanon's coastline and
breaking sectarian divides by holding
hands so we're making this a human chain
to show the the full support of all the
Lebanese people together despite
promises of economic reforms by Prime
Minister Saad Hariri the people have not
left the streets after 11 days of
protests their message the same as on
day one we want to fight the corruption
that's happening in our country that's
been happening for the past thirty years
so now this is the this is the people
speaking this is our time we argued
basically for one thing it's just to get
our basic rights and hopefully we'll get
there what do you mean by basic rights
if we can start by garbage on the
streets if we can like electricity water
everything the core message from the
protesters is that the government must
resign people tell us they want they
need new faces I left Lebanon in the in
the 90s and when I come back after 30
years still we have the same names the
same government people nothing is
changing look at the state of the
infrastructure and you can understand
the people who are running or governing
the country how bad they are
this was a show of solidarity of this
fractious population standing together
under the Lebanese flag it's a second
Sunday of these protests and they're
cool for the entire government to resign
has gone unheeded the question is well
these protests maintain their momentum
and if they do how long will the
government let them go on for Stephanie
Decker al Jazeera Beirut